we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i've gotten
a lot of messages lately from people
asking what happened to the Eggman
is the Eggman dead why haven't we heard
from the Eggman because i'm trying to
introduce a little levity into the
voicemail segment because a lot of the
news lately is not not very positive i
have an example today of why we are not
hearing from the Eggman for whatever
reason for the last several months every
voicemail that the Eggman leaves the
Eggman is a is a former federal prisoner
who lives in upstate New York and is
just a nice guy and he was uh he was in
prison on some drug charges and he's a
good guy he's a good dog owner he's a
good father all of that stuff anyway
we've been hearing from him for years
for some reason months ago every time
the Eggman calls in it sounds like he's
underwater and I just can't play the
voicemails for you because we can't
understand a word he's saying I will
play one for you and you will see
exactly what I mean
take a listen to this okay I think you
guys get the idea I'm picking up some
words Cuomo Alex Jones essential is he
standing fifty feet from his phone is he
in some kind of bunker I don't know what
is going on with Eggman but we can't do
this is not the phone quality that our
viewers have come to expect okay I
understood that how many businesses are
hiring law firms to claim that they are
now essential businesses
so anyway Eggman is very much alive he's
still calling in but Eggman you've got
to fix your phone please please please
do something there so we can we can hear
you better okay on the bonus show today
it turns out that Obama administration
officials did a tried to do a training
with Trump aides about how to handle a
global pandemic this was an exercise
is back in 2017 turns out they didn't
learn much many of them just didn't
attend we also have learned that there
are starting to be prisoner releases of
non-violent prisoners because of the
virus threat we are going to explore how
Ohio is managing it and look at whether
this might be adopted in other states
and then lastly when we talk about
priorities legislative priorities often
Idaho is very backwards and Idaho has
not passed anything related to the virus
but in the last week they have passed
two anti-transgender bills priorities
right priorities a make sure you join me
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member at join pakman.com
or becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show not only do you
get instant access to the bonus show you
also get a commercial free audio and
video feed of the show every single day
I'll talk to you excuse me I'll talk to
you then